that report came out in 2021 it's called
The Power of TV and it's how to use
television to encourage people to
decarbonize their Lifestyles and there's
something I think was quite incredible
about this what they talked about are
basically was using the whole gamut of
Sky's programming from news weather
reports children's programming drama
documentaries
to make people aware of the extent of
climate change and what they can do
about it we used to propaganda
in other countries we think of
propaganda on TV as The Preserve maybe
of communist or authoritarian countries
and it's quite a surprise to see a
report published here in this country
about a unit which was owned one-third
by government
collaborating with a licensed
broadcaster
on how to change our mind about a
subject which we're told the science
system but it's clearly still
contentious to further
a political goal because in its areas of
political goal and this is propaganda
you know that is propaganda